le cinéma français a récompensé les
siens hier soir la cuvée des césars 96
est plutôt consensuel irons-nous avec le
prix du meilleur film à mathieu
kassovitz pour la haine mais aussi le
titre de meilleur acteur masculin à
michel serrault pour son interprétation
dans nelly et monsieur arnaud et un prix
particulièrement émouvant celui du
meilleur second rôle féminin attribué à
annie girardot qui pour la circonstance
occupait le devant de la scène ils sont
là tous les deux mais avant retour sur
la série me pascal les champs michel
anglade éparpillé façon puzzle et césar
hier soir ou quatre coins du cinéma
français quand la haine reçoit celui du
meilleur film
sennels lié monsieur arnaud qui voit
tout se pète celui du meilleur
réalisateur
quand les trois frères est consacrée
meilleure première oeuvre
josiane balasko et gazon maudit
repartent avec le césar du meilleur
scénario
côté comédien eddy mitchell meilleur
second rôle a trouvé le bonheur dans le
fric et isabelle huppert lui fois nominé
était cette fois la meilleure actrice
pour la cérémonie dont elle partage la
vedette avec sandrine bonnaire en a déjà
eu deux césar moi j'en ai jamais eu
alors quoi
un éparpillement des récompenses qui ont
fait bien la diversité du cru 95
confirmée par le choix du public avec
35% de parts de marché le cinéma
français n'avait pas connu un tel
bonheur depuis longtemps du bonheur
attendu longtemps trop longtemps aussi
par annie girardot meilleur second rôle
dans les misérables
depuis sa sortie j'ai manqué au cinéma
français mais à moi le cinéma français a
manqué follement éperdument
douloureusement
votre témoignage votre amour me font
penser que peut-être
je dis bien peut-être je suis pas encore
tout à fait morte
et lorsque michel ciron meilleur acteur
très ému aussi donc sur scène il a une
de ces manière d'enfoncer le clou qui a
dû faire regretter à plus d'un la
cruauté parfois l'amnésie souvent de la
profession cette grande dame dit il
méritait mieux
je trouve que pour un second rôle
j'ai eu de la peine c'est un beau moment
vrai et vous rideau